today we are going to have a drag queen
flash makeup expert explained to us what
to do to our faces and we will follow
those instructions blindly and put
makeup on I've seen a couple of seasons
of RuPaul's Drag Race also I know about
contouring the Kardashians like the
contour
I've never contoured I don't know how to
do it I know it's a lot of like hitting
your face yeah hi guys my name is Kate
Moss today kids we have to makeup
novices and they're gonna listen to
every little thing I tell them to do and
hopefully they look stunning when
they're done otherwise I'm trash at the
end I and all of you will judge who did
the best face last yes yeah I guess our
first first step will be cover your
whole entire face and foundation which
one's the foundation the foundation
probably the one that looks like your
skin color okay you can squirt a little
on the sponge and just kind of dab dab
dab dab dab dab dab dab yeah I'm kind of
like you're slapping yourself in the
face of the sponge how do I look oh
you're already doing better than me oh
my god process usually it's very
different with everyone most girls can
do look sickening in 30 minutes or some
girls need a whole two hours from start
to finish we're not really gonna do full
drag face today we're just gonna get
them a light daytime beat oh honey I
look like I'm about to go to a funeral
potentially my own okay it's a little
corpse light do we have any Browns
we're gonna carve your guys's faces out
oh my god this is the Kardashian part
you can use liquid contour you can use
powder it all depends on your type of
skin and/or just how you like to do
makeup how about one of you do powder
one of you cream okay so since you're
doing cream do just a little bit and
suck your cheeks in like you're a fish
and then go from like you're from the
base
your sideburns and just do a little line
for the cream do a little line kind of
like right before the ball of your cheek
do your brown on your cheek does it
matter which Brown um yeah kind of go
for a little lighter brown cuz you guys
both have lighter skin tones so if it's
too dark
you're gonna look scary she only needs a
little bit with the cream you gotta
blend it and blend it and blend it do
you think mine's heavy enough if you
don't think it's dark enough it could be
darker do you have cream too well here's
the thing mexica Simpson over here okay
do you have a drag name no I think
that's the one thing that keeps me from
doing anything fun like that good name
yourselves when you're done I have a
dragon even though I've never done
driving oh she does what is it chlorine
I'm done with you you always also have
to outline your jaw so go from like the
base of your jaw
I love how Kate can't even see you but
can tell that you're oh my god when
you're done putting the cream in your
face take one of those sponges literally
start like beating your face again and
just blending it and blending it and
blending it and blending and blending it
and it'll look a lot better I promise
I know I'm probably you know but I can't
tell exactly I don't know man I really
like it
do you yeah it still looks like I'm a
kind of a sick baby so I want you guys
to take your eyeliner and start from the
corner of your eyebrows darken them and
fill them in a little bit woo that went
zero to sixty fast Kate how are we doing
oh did you ruin your eyebrow I decided
I'm just going all out that's fine
subtle
there is nothing subtle about daytime
drag don't touch it cuz it's gonna go oh
I'm doing it okay hey if you like it I
love it how about that you would have
been better if you used any sort of
normal looking here oh crap this is
where
is where it ends for me oh well actually
I kind of did it
let us like I think every drag queens
pet peeve is that when you put liquid
eyeliner on your lids you accidentally
like look up for a second it translates
you automatically have a crease and it's
all black I didn't can't get it off wait
can you do it yeah
I'm sorry am I not explaining it good
enough real or een no I'm a visual
learner boy does it have to be brown or
could you choose like a flirty color you
could go with any color you want really
how about a blue go ahead I love blue
you're gonna go clean up around your
eyebrows with if you had white you would
use the white but you guys have a
highlighter that's kind of white oh I'm
gonna go this blue right here is it like
super outrageous iMessage blue yeah
that's probably the closest to iMessage
blue so basically you're cleaning up the
crease now so like the crease will still
be there and just I have that and they
should connect to your nose I think my
makeup technique is like it up and then
rub it in harder a lot of queens that do
that they just slap makeup on their
faces and just rub it in and up that's
wrong and they just add more over and
then at the end they look gorgeous are
you guys done with the creases sure yeah
okay we're gonna go back to the fish the
fish suck at the very end of your
contour put some blush and then try to
end kind of blend it in a little bit
just the dab will do you I wish you had
told me that how many times have I said
subtle blending is your friend okay crap
Oh see she said they were still time for
mistakes oh boy did she deliver you guys
have lipsticks yeah yeah okay then just
over draw them your drag name can be
scarlet fever thank you if your lipstick
still have the tip on it you can use the
tip to outline and like draw your lips
just a little bit bigger to give them a
little more fullness you got a sign you
take the lash and you put it start at
the base corner of your eye and lay it
gently across and like it should meet
like the end of your lash oh boy this is
gonna be a good adventure let me tell
you
Oh God Kade what's up buddy not good
thing oh wait I got it look yes you look
really good I'm so excited I wonder how
much they're lying to each other oh god
what was that noise glued my eye shed
you just sounded like a goose I think
yeah you hold it out like this and then
you just paint that do you want me to
help you blend into your eye shadow yeah
since she gave you that drag name you
can help blend her eye your eyelashes
are on your eyelid that's why I can't
close my eyes oh yeah they're glued
there alright this is where they sit now
and what about it okay girls brushes
down it's time to inspect your faces so
now is the moment of truth here's our
first painter miss kate a.k.a scarlet
fever you did the cream contour and
everything mm-hmm I should check that
out I don't really have any criticisms
she did a really good job like it looks
like she was just rushing to get ready
for work maybe a little more contour and
just place your eyelashes on a regular
spot what where do I put my eyelashes
well oh this one right here is kind of
on your eye uh-huh but it's just SS to
stay on the line Oh true as it is keep
her on the line keep around the line
what about this one
I think feel like this yeah I know she
know she's there oh she's on the line
the whole way across man putting on
eyelashes really goes against basic ins
yes at home maybe some white white
eyeliner make your eyes look a little
bigger ladies and gentlemen this reveal
please just come
oh my gosh you look like the tan mom
thank you look what you guys were
talking man it seemed like you did a
really bad job but obviously it just
looks like you had your eyebrows blew
down and did three performances back to
back to back to back to back and your
eyebrows came out I'm booked and busy
what can I say
you listened I tried I like the pink lip
you chose I thought it seemed like the
obvious choice you did such a great job
of like explaining stuff to us on the
fly so it definitely was really helpful
I know it's probably like it looks a
little bit like a kindergartner did it
I'm so impressed with how Kate did he
might not be impressed with how I did
but I love you very much
no offense daughter it's all right but
miss scarlet fever lens you're never won
anything
constantly win thank you guys so much
for watching the back-to-back makeup
challenge let us know in the comments so
you thought was the winner and if you
thought I was right now you didn't wear
them thank you guys for watching so much
me
[Music]
[Music]